Je peux vous en donner mille exemples tirés des sciences,
mais il en est un que j'adore, lié à l'astronomie,
une question qui taraude les astronomes
littéralement depuis des siècles.
Si vous regardez le Soleil, il paraît unique.
Il est l'objet le plus brillant du ciel.
Mais l'astronomie, la physique, la chimie, la thermodynamique,
nous ont appris au fil des siècles quelque chose de très important.
Le Soleil n'est pas si unique.
Il n'est qu'une étoile parmi des millions d'autres étoiles.
Cela soulève une question intéressante.
Si le Soleil est une étoile
et que le Soleil a des planètes,
les autres étoiles ont-elles des planètes ?
Eh bien ! Comme je le racontais à propos de mon échec avec ma « planète »,
les trouver est super compliqué,
mais les scientifiques sont plutôt des gens intelligents
et, grâce à plein de techniques diverses,
ils ont observé les étoiles.
Au fil des décennies,
ils ont trouvé des trucs assez intéressants,
là, à l'extrême limite de leurs capacités de détection.
Mais, chaque fois, c'étaient de fausses pistes.
Puis tout a changé en 1991.
Deux astronomes,
Andrew Lyne et Matthew Bailes,
ont fait une annonce phénoménale.
Ils avaient trouvé une planète tournant autour d'une autre étoile.
Et pas n'importe quelle étoile, un pulsar.
Un pulsar résulte de l'explosion d'une étoile
et émet un très fort rayonnement.
C'est le dernier endroit de l'univers où on s'imagine trouver une planète !
Mais ils avaient étudié le pulsar très méthodiquement
et avaient détecté la trace de la planète gravitant autour du pulsar.
Ça semblait affaire réglée :
on avait découvert pour la première fois une planète autour d'une autre étoile !
Sauf que, non.
(Rires)
Suite à l'annonce, nombre d'astronomes ont émis des commentaires.
Aussi ont-ils dû revoir leurs calculs,
et ils ont découvert une erreur bien embarrassante.
Ils avaient négligé de subtiles caractéristiques
du mouvement de la Terre autour du Soleil,
ce qui avait corrompu leur mesure de l'orbite de la planète.
La suite ? Ils ont corrigé leurs calculs,
et paf ! leur planète avait disparu.
Elle n'existait pas.
Andrew Lyne fut alors confronté à une épreuve effrayante.
Il devait admettre son erreur.
Aussi, en 1992, à la rencontre de la Société américaine d'astronomie,
qui est un des plus grands rassemblements d'astronomes de la planète,
il s'est levé et a annoncé qu'il avait fait une erreur
et que la planète n'existait pas.
Ce qu'il s'est passé ensuite...
Oh ! j'adore ce passage !
Ce qu'il s'est passé ensuite est merveilleux.
Il a reçu une ovation.
Les astronomes n'étaient pas fâchés contre lui.
Ils ne l'ont pas vilipendé.
Ils l'ont loué pour son honnêteté et son intégrité.
Qu'est-ce que j'aime ça !
Les scientifiques sont comme vous et moi ! (Rires)
Et la suite est encore mieux !
(Rires)
Lyne redescend du podium.
Celui qui y monte ensuite s'appelle Alexsander Wolszczan.
Il prend le microphone et dit :
« Bon, l'équipe de Lyne n'a pas trouvé de planète de pulsar.
Mais mon équipe, elle, a trouvé, non pas une,
mais deux planètes, gravitant autour d'un autre pulsar !
Nous avions eu vent du problème rencontré par Lyne,
nous avons donc vérifié, et oui, les nôtres sont réelles. »
Et il se trouve qu'il avait raison.
En fait, quelques mois plus tard,
ils ont trouvé une troisième planète autour de ce pulsar,
et c'était la toute première découverte d'un système d'exoplanètes,
des exoplanètes que nous appelons des mondes extraterrestres.
Je trouve ça tout simplement merveilleux.
Les vannes étaient désormais grandes ouvertes.
En 1995, une planète fut trouvée
autour d'une étoile plus semblable au Soleil.
Puis une autre, et une autre encore.
Voici une image d'une planète réelle autour d'une vraie étoile.
Nous avons sans cesse progressé,
trouvant des exoplanètes par brassées entières.
Nous nous sommes mis à en trouver des milliers.
Nous avons créé des observatoires conçus spécialement pour les chercher.
Nous en connaissons désormais des milliers.
Nous avons même connaissance de systèmes planétaires.
Voici une animation montrant quatre exoplanètes autour de leur étoile.
C'est incroyable. Réfléchissez un instant !
De toute l'histoire de l'humanité,
on a compté les planètes connues sur deux mains seulement.
Neuf ! Huit ?
Neuf ! Huit ! Huit !
(Rires)
Hein !
Mais désormais, nous savons qu'il y en a partout !
Chaque étoile,
pour chaque étoile du firmament, il peut y avoir trois, cinq, dix planètes.
Le ciel en est rempli !
Il y a probablement plus de planètes que d'étoiles dans la galaxie.
C'est une affirmation bouleversante,
qui est rendue possible par la science.
Et pas tant grâce à la science, aux observatoires et aux données !
Grâce surtout aux scientifiques qui ont construit ces observatoires,
collecté les données,
fait des erreurs, les ont reconnues,
puis ont permis à d'autres scientifiques de bâtir à partir de leurs erreurs
afin que la science puisse œuvrer,
et qu'on puisse percer le mystère de notre place dans l'univers.
C'est comme cela qu'on trouve la vérité.
La science est à son zénith quand elle ose se faire humaine.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et vivats)